why is it that most literature reviews
put everyone to sleep while others seem
to somehow pull us in as though we're
watching a superhero action movie and
why is it that those literature reviews
keep on receiving citation after
citation While most others are ignored
or forgotten well in my own experience
working with graduate students I have
discovered some patterns that academic
writers use to write and publish
successful literature reviews and in
today's video I'm going to reveal those
patterns to you and show you how you can
use them to write a lit review that'll
leave your editors and readers saying
Avengers Assemble I understood that
reference if you're new here my name is
William and I'm an English Professor
working with some of the brightest
scientists and engineers in South Korea
and this first tip about literature
reviews is something that I discovered
when I was doing my undergraduate degree
not in science and engineering but in
English literature now a lot of people
used to tease me by saying that studying
English literature would have no real
world benefit and they were absolutely
right but this first tip has actually
proven quite useful when it comes to
writing literature reviews and I think
the easiest way to make this point would
be to take a look at the literary
Masterpiece The Avengers the basic plot
of the story is that at the start Loki
steals the tesser act and threatens
Earth which leads Nick Fury to activate
the Avengers Initiative The Avengers
meet clash and then come together to
fight against Loki and his alien Army in
a massive battle in New York City at the
end of the film spoiler alert The
Avengers defeat Loki and go their
separate ways that is what we in the
English literature Biz call the plot of
the film it's the series of events that
you see on the screen when you're
sitting there watching the movie but
what many people don't realize is that
there's actually another layer of the
film that we don't see because it's not
always shown on screen this layer
includes not only the events of the film
itself but also all the characters
backstories and motivations for example
it includes how The Avengers became who
they are like how Tony Stark became Iron
Man or how Steve Rogers transformed into
Captain America Loki's histories and
motivations what's this guy's problem
anyway and the actions of Shield leading
up to the formation of the Avengers this
second layer is called the story it's
bigger than the plot it includes the
broader narrative that the plot is a
part of it includes all the parts that
might be hinted at or suggested but that
you don't see directly on screen so to
recap the events that you see on the
screen are called the plot and
everything in the background that
deepens and enriches that plot is called
the story but what does this have to do
with literature reviews I'm glad you
asked the place where so many academic
writers go wrong in the literature
review is that they just list all the
research that's been done before and
that makes the reader feel as though
they're reading through a phone book in
other words they forget that the
literature review is supposed to tell a
story now to be fair many of these
academic writers will organize This
research according to certain criteria
like when it was published or the
country the research was conducted in or
the field or the discipline Etc they'll
organize it under these headings but
organization is not a story it's just
the plot it doesn't pull the reader in
because it's just information as a quick
meta example we're getting a little bit
Inception in here why did we take this
time to talk about the Avengers why
didn't I just sit here and say here are
three things that you should do in your
literature review you get it people like
a story it's what pulls Us in and makes
us open and receptive to the information
so here are some things that you can do
to make sure that your literature review
goes beyond the plot and tells a story
first you really want to cast your
literature review carefully just like in
The Avengers there are main characters
such as Captain America and Thor well
similarly in your literature review
there are going to be primary studies
these are the key sources the studies
that are most relevant and impactful for
your research topic
they're the ones that drive the plot of
your literature review so you want to
select them carefully and really bring
out their key insights and findings now
of course in all good stories alongside
these major characters are minor
characters like Hawkeye or black widow
now their role is important but it's not
Central it's kind of supporting the main
roles of the primary characters these
supporting characters are not the focus
of the story and you would probably
never see them in a scene of their own
but when they do appear in a scene
alongside one of the main characters
they help to bring out some aspect of
that character's personality or struggle
through comparison and contrast well
similarly you want to think what are the
minor studies and how can I position
them alongside the major studies in
order to bring out some deeper meaning
through comparison and contrast these
minor studies should not really appear
in paragraphs of their own they probably
won't receive integral citations they'll
they'll be less dominant in the way that
you write about them but their
positioning can really help to bring out
some of the major findings in your
primary sources so as you're sorting
through all the studies in your
literature review you can think about
which of these would be considered
allies to the primary characters in your
literature riew that is which ones share
similar methodologies or similar
findings and conversely which ones would
be considered adversaries those which
contradict or complicate the major
characters in your literature review
finally a good movie is never going to
have a character that doesn't contribute
in some way to the story so you should
leave out sources that don't contribute
meaningfully to the story that you're
telling you need to be quite selective
in the characters that you let in to
your literature review everybody in
there should be important and
contributing in some way to the single
story that you're trying to tell in this
literature review now I'll admit writing
an academic literature review is
probably not going to be quite as
thrilling as writing a Marvel superhero
movie but you do not need to be a
Hollywood writer in order to bring this
research to life all you need is to be
able to see the forest through the trees
the trees are the plot it's all the
research that has been conducted on your
topic and our goal here is to reveal a
pattern in all of these studies that
makes our research look like the missing
piece of the puzzle now normally what
academic writers will do when they're
Gathering all this research is to
organize it into a grid using either a
spreadsheet or academic software like
zoto and while I'm a big fan of having a
method of organizing all your files I
really don't think that it's a good
first step when you are developing your
literature review because take a look at
this here's all the research that I
gathered on the tessera it's an exciting
field of research and I've organized it
into a matrix according to certain
criteria such as when it was published
or the country in which the research was
conducted or the field of research or
its findings and that makes good sense
but the problem that I see in organizing
a literature review into a grid like
this is that it imposes a grid on our
thinking and we don't naturally think
this way our mind is not organized into
a grid this has been called the linear
straight jacket and this linear thinking
is what I think causes so many writers
to miss the forest and get lost in the
trees now in just a moment I'm going to
show you how you can really bring out
that Forest using certain storytelling
techniques but first what I really want
to make clear here is the reason why
we're spending so much attention in
bringing out this story and it's because
we can never demonstrate the value of
our research if the story that we tell
about it is first this happened then
this study happened then he published
this and now I did this report that's
not valuable that's just information so
instead of this grid I recommend using a
mind map technique in which you write
your research topic in the middle and
then you think of just certain hooks the
the big topics that come to mind when
you the writer think about that topic
then you can start to rearrange all this
research to think where does it fit and
that will reveal the major and minor
characters in your story and it'll also
give you a really good way of
positioning your research next to it all
but now what I really want to get into
is some technique that you can use in
telling your literature review story
because the way that you tell this story
is just as important as the story itself
we have to come back to our purpose why
are we telling this literature review
story we want to persuade the reader
specifically we want to persuade the
reader that our research is a meaningful
and important contribution to the field
we want them to like us and then accept
our research and say hey this is is good
stuff and persuasion is not just a
matter of telling a story it also
involves selecting the right words so
that you can engage with that literature
and with the reader in ways that are
socially appropriate take a look at
these two movie reviews for The Avengers
one is from The Wall Street Journal and
the other is from The New Yorker there's
a really big and important difference in
the way that the authors are using
personal pronouns so let me read them to
you and see if you can catch it in the
Wall Street Journal the author says I'll
explain the asteris later the asteris in
case you don't know is that little star
symbol and it appears in one sentence
before so I'll explain the asteris later
first let me note the magnitude of the
event for the movie's fan base versus
the Oddity of the mashup a slow start a
single star performance surrounded by
indifferent acting and an onslaught of
computer effects that range from scen it
all and Transformers to a whole Sky Full
of spectacular stuff in the Midtown
Manhattan climax that's the Wall Street
Journal but compare that with this short
passage from the article in the New
Yorker I couldn't understand a word
until he asked quote the humans what can
they do but burn if he is referring to
our cooking skills this is grossly
unfair for we can also poach broil
gently simmer and steam on Palo now
there are a few things that we could say
about those movie reviews but again the
one that I want to draw your attention
to is the way these authors are using
personal pronouns like I me and you I
think there is a really big difference
between saying I'll explain this later
and saying I couldn't understand a word
he was saying now in that first case
when the writer in the Wall Street
Journal says I'll explain this later
that personal pronoun I is pointing
inside the text to what Eric hayatt
calls the author function of the paper I
mean it's not like the author is going
to meet you for lunch later and explain
this to you it's an I that only exists
inside the text it's like saying I think
or I argue you the personal pronoun I
represents an author that exists only
inside the text but that second case
when the New Yorker tells us about what
it was like to sit there and watch the
movie and not understand what the
characters were saying that points
outside the text to a real Flesh and
Blood author a character that has just
entered the representational space of
the text and by introducing this new
character into the text the author
creates that second layer that we were
talking about earlier in the Wall Street
Journal there's just this flat one layer
it's a movie review but in the New
Yorker piece by introducing this Flesh
and Blood author the one who went to go
see the movie and was sitting there and
couldn't understand what the characters
were saying that character introduces
this second layer so we have the plot
which is the movie review and the story
which is the underlying Narrative of how
that author got up one day and went to
the movies and watched a movie and the
New Yorker piece really does a great job
at bringing out this story level we see
a lot of the author in the narrative not
only through the use of personal
pronouns but also through his references
to pop culture and funny side comments
all that personality really helps to
develop the character in the story and
now we as the reader are watching a
story and we are a lot more willing to
accept the writer's opinions and
criticisms of the movie if we can
identify with the character in that
story it's the story that allows the
writer to make a much more personal
connection with the reader and when the
reader has a personal connection to the
writer they're a lot more persuadable
they're a lot more willing to follow the
reader through all the details of the
research and to be persuaded by The
Writer's conclusions and and ideas now I
know that a common piece of writing
advice that gets thrown around in
academic writing circles is to not use
the personal pronoun I and you can do
that if you want to it's going to tell a
different kind of story the story that
it'll tell is one of a researcher who's
small and in the background and wants to
put the spotlight onto the research
itself it doesn't make for a very
compelling story but you might want to
do that in cases where you're talking
about your own research and you don't
want to come across as arrogant or too
self- congratulating well you can take
yourself out of the equation and just
talk about the research as though it
exists on it own or if you were dealing
with a controversial research topic you
might not want to name people directly
you might just want to talk about these
beliefs as though they exist on their
own in those cases it's understandable
to avoid using personal pronouns but
this second use of personal pronouns
that we see in the New Yorker article
creates a much more engaging
multi-dimensional story with a Persona
that the reader can really get to like
and trust and when the reader likes and
Trust you they're going to be a lot more
persuadable and that's our goal here we
want to persuade the reader that our
research is Meaningful and important now
all right real talk there is a
widespread
misconception come here that academic
writing should be formal and impersonal
and I think that's why so many writers
have difficulty getting published and
receiving citations because research
shows that articles which are written in
an informal tone and from a more
personal Voice receive the most
citations and get published in the
highest impact journals so to learn how
you can use this research to write
articles that receive more citations and
get published in better journals you
need to check out this video right here
because it's going to show you how to
use personal pronouns and two other
language items to receive more citations
and get more Publications so be sure to
go check it
out